robert habeck gestern das ergebnis
dieses stresstests verkündet zwei
deutsche akw werden ende 22 vom netz
gehen und bis april aber im reserve
modus weiter arbeiten wie zufrieden bist
du mit dieser entscheidung die frage ist
was ist die zielsetzung dieser
entscheidung da gibt es eine die sagt
wir wollen einen black out verhindern
blackout heißt wenn wir irgendwann in
dieser krise im winter in eine situation
kommen wo plötzlich tatsächlich das
stromnetz zusammen bricht dann könnte es
zudem kommen was man dränge auf nennt
mit konsequenzen die kein mensch will
und das ist sozusagen eine
sicherheitsmaßnahme in einem eher sehr
unwahrscheinlichen fall denn das wurde
auch auf der pressekonferenz deutlich
dass man einfach sagte okay man hat das
als reserve aber das ist jetzt nicht im
grunde genommen der game changer wenn es
um die hohen preise geht wenn es um die
gesamte andere thematik lasst uns bitte
da bleiben und lasst uns den runde mal
aufwachen weil das ist glaube ich das
was die leute wirklich interessiert
erklären mir einmal ich bin kein
physiker danach bin ich gespannt auf der
mathematiker in der runde warum ist das
kein game changer ich habe dieser tage
leonhard birnbaum gelesen den
vorstandsvorsitzenden von ehe und er
sagte natürlich hat das an den
signifikanten effekt wenn wir diese
meiler weiter laufen lassen weil der
name schlicht mehr strom im markt und
wenn die preise so exponentiell wachsen
dann hat das natürlich an den einfluss
auf die preisentwicklung warum sagst du
nein aus mehreren gründen also das erste
ist in der relevanz wir reden hier von
dem was momentan in deutschen
kraftwerken produziert wird von einem
strohmann teil der eher gering ist er
ist so in der größenordnung von 6 7
prozent
das ist also nicht viel im vergleich zu
anderen ländern bisschen was ein
bisschen was das zweite ist wir haben in
diesem sommer wenn wir wirklich mal bei
der kernenergie bleiben eigentlich
interessante lektion aus frankreich
erlebt weil frankreich hat nicht nur das
problem dass sie viele meiler haben die
repariert werden die uralt sind aber
aufgrund der niedrigen pegel war ist so
dass sie gezwungen waren viele
kernkraftwerke
runterzufahren abzustellen und waren
froh dass es strom aus deutschland gab
in form von sonnen- oder windenergie
also und und gas und gas auch aber wir
haben wir haben alles und das ist der
punkt auf den ich hinaus will wir haben
in diesem jahr und das auch die frage an
boris palmer und dann roderich
kiesewetter alles bot was in dem thema
auch drin wir haben in diesem jahr im
mai und im juli so viel gas zu strom
gemacht wie noch nie in der geschichte
dieses landes und ehrlich gesagt komme
ich da als normaler bürger nicht mehr
mit mein gefühl ist demnächst schickt
mir die regierung einen einen
zuständigen beamten der morgens bei mir
im badezimmer steht und gucken wie lange
du musst du eigentlich
und wie teilt vor allen dingen genau und
gleichzeitig machen wir dieses wertvolle
gas und da gibt es ja noch einen anderen
aspekt nämlich die frage der industrie
dagegen arbeitsplätze gerade wirklich in
mengen über die wupper schlicht und
ergreifend warum machen wir dieses
wertvolle gas so leichtfertig zustrom
die es gibt nicht eine einfache antwort
aber es gibt eine die am ende damit
zusammenhängt dass sie über jahre eine
falsche strategie gefahren haben
gas war das wissen wir alle unglaublich
günstig wir haben hier in deutschland
gas bezogen eigentlich von einer nation
also da kann man jetzt für oder gegen
russland sein aber jeder normale mensch
würde sagen wenn ich ein so wichtiges
gut habe dann stelle ich mich breiter
auf ich habe sozusagen nicht nur ein
sondern mehrere lieferanten das war
nicht der fall und in der folge aufgrund
der günstigen preise
entwickelte sich etwas wo man gesagt hat
okay wir nutzen gas in form zb von kraft
wärme kopplung erzählt er
das ist eine langfristige sünde die die
wir begangen haben und die uns langsam
auf die füße fällt ich meine wir haben
ein echtes problem und das sind immer
probleme die damit zusammenhängen mit
entscheidungen die vor jahren falsch
getroffen worden dabei sehen sie genauso
weiß die vergangenheit angeht ja stimme
ich zu
wobei wir natürlich
interessant die argumentation von von
raoul weil er sagte im sommer hat der
frankreich jetzt ein problem ich bin
heute morgen in hamburg wach geworden
habe gemerkt geht deutlich auf den
winter zu das heißt der sommer ist kein
argument die frage ist was passiert in
diesem winter und da auch wenn sie die
frage warum macht es keinen sinn akw
weiter laufen zu lassen diesen strom von
dem wir sagen wir brauchen alles was
geht noch ein bisschen zu nutzen
wenigstens okay also wenn es die akw
frage ist dann ist das erste argument
rein quantitativ es ist kein game
changer dafür sind einfach zu wenige die
noch übrig sind vor zehn jahren hätten
wir eine andere menge gesprochen jetzt
ist es schon so klein wir reden ja nur
von denen die noch laufen und das ist
nicht der game changer sein kann und die
entscheidung die robert habeck jetzt
getroffen habe ist insoweit klug als sie
ja im gesetz eine veränderung voraus ist
da steht ja bisher der betrieb eines
atomkraftwerks ist nach dem 31 dezember
verboten und was ja jetzt angekündigt
hat ist dass dieses verbot rausgeschoben
wird auf ende april glaube ich das heißt
es gibt so sein vorschlag eine
rechtliche möglichkeit die wir nicht
haben im notfall diese kraftwerke zu
benutzen das scheint mir der lage
durchaus angemessen zu sein aber ein
game changer kann es nicht sein dafür
ist die menge zu klein
ich höre da gerade parteipolitik br&gt
wörter wie sehen sie das nicht
parteipolitik sondern wenn wir sehen
dass die kernkraftwerke die wir haben
rund 5 bis 6 prozent des stromes leisten
dann bedeutet es was anderes für baden
württemberg und bayern sehr industrie
laste ich dort kernkraftwerke leisten
etwa 15 prozent der dortigen
stromversorgung insofern würde eine
verlängerung bedeuten dass wir gerade
für süddeutschland wo das industrielle
herz schlägt und hoffentlich noch lange
wie eine entlastung bekommen der zweite
punkt sie haben dort auch ihren
wahlkreis ja und er wird wir werden
direkt gewählt er in tübingen und ich an
alle wissen was
wir haben große firmen bei uns wir haben
firmen die batterien erzeugen haben aber
auch für die ungeheuer gas intensiv sind
im maschinenbau und anderen also oder
papierindustrie also bereit die
kraftwerke weiterlaufen können aber
jetzt kommt der punkt würde ich diesmal
umrechnen auf die bevölkerung dann hat
einer reichen drei kernkraftwerke etwas
stromerzeugung für zehn millionen
menschen
ich will jetzt nicht sagen wir müssen
die drei die wir schon abgeschaltet
haben auch noch verlängern wäre es 94
millionen menschen aber um es mal
griffig zu machen dass die
stromerzeugung für zehn millionen
menschen und der zweite punkt den wir
leisten müssen ist neben der
verlängerung dass wir die last pascal
kraftwerke aus der strompreis ordnung
nehmen dann hätten wir eine entlastung
ich glaube das ist dem kurzen sich auf
zustimmung habe robert habeck den sieger
zitiert haben ich hab mir das externe
rausgeholt der hat eingeräumt dieser
tage dass der weiterbetrieb der
kernkraftwerke ist genau dieses argument
vor allem diese teureren gaskraftwerke
aus dem markt drücken würde das bedeutet
doch übersetzt der strompreis würde
sinken oder nicht nur mal innerhalb wir
brauchen dafür tatsächlich was anderes
es sind so viele gaskraftwerke so das so
im markt dass deren preis immer der ist
der bestimmt was der strom kostet an der
börse das ist zwar ein bisschen
kompliziert aber mal ganz einfach gesagt
wenn ich eine solaranlage betreibe damit
steht die heute genauso viel wie vor
einem jahr weil die sonne ist nicht
teurer geworden das sind 67 18 die
kilowattstunde
diesen strom wenn ich dafür 6 78 cent
die kilowattstunde erzeuge und die
stadtwerke tübingen erzeugen zwei
drittel des strombedarfs von tübingen
aus solar und wind wo sind ihre
windparks und ihre foto greiner gerade
außerhalb thüringens aber zumindest in
teilen baden würden bei uns alle in
deutschland und wir haben sie auch bis
brandenburg das heißt die stadtwerke
tübingen betreiben deutschlandweit
windparks und solaranlagen
das war eine strategie die ich aus
klimaschutzgründen die letzten 16 jahre
vorangetrieben habe mein argument war
wenn man damit noch kein geld verdient
ist es jedenfalls klimaschutz umsonst
viel verdient hat man damit nicht aber
wir konnten klimaschutz machen und
deswegen heute als staat bei zwei
drittel selbst erzeugtem strom aus sonne
und wie bei der ich heute genauso billig
wie von dem jahr die erzeugung die
erzeugung ist genauso wie nager
verkaufen kann man den strom geht es für
den zehnfachen preis an der börse weil
der preis wird nicht bestimmt durch den
durchschnittswert der erzeugungskosten
so würde man sich das vielleicht denken
so als verbraucher sondern das teuerste
kraftwerk das noch gebraucht hat
bestimmt den preis für alles und das
teuerste kraftwerk ist immer ein
gaskraftwerk vargas viel zu teuer
geworden ist und alle gaskraftwerk
herauszunehmen aus dem markt wird nicht
gelingen auch dann nicht wenn die
atomkraftwerke weiterlaufen würden weil
wir 13 prozent gasverstromung haben 06
atom das heißt die preisbildung bleibt
bei dem gras kraft nicht billiger weil
wir immer noch gas brauchen nur eins in
betrieb ist genauso teuer wie vorher
davon gehe ich erstmal auswirft beim
preis gewinnen wenn nichts da müssten
wir ja wenn ich ganz bei ihnen herr
kiesewetter wir müssten den mechanismus
mit dem strompreise gebildet werden
außer kraft setzen uns noch mal ganz
kurz wir halten die ihre stadtwerke
tübingen verdienen sich gerade eine
goldene nase an dieser krise wie bei den
kraftwerken die gegen den markt
verkaufen können wir zehnmal mehr
erlösen als wir kosten haben in der
produktionshalle das heißt sie machen
die stadtwerke keine ausnahme das heißt
sie machen zufalls gewinne sind reine
zufalls gewinne krise wurde ich finde
wenn sie sich dafür dass sie da
besteuert werden extra besteuert werden
ich spreche dagegen dass ich diese
gewinne mache also wir haben auf einer
basis kalkuliert
ist reguliert von sieben cent und ich
möchte gar eine anständige
eigenkapitalverzinsung von 5 dann möchte
ich gern für 8 cent verkaufen können
aber ich will nicht für 70 cent an der
börse verkaufen weil das geld ja
woanders fehlt also dadurch dass jetzt
die produzenten von strom sich eine
goldene nase verdienen dass sie noch
ganz andere unterwegs bei kohle ist es
nicht anders ich war der
produktionspreis hat sich nur verdoppelt
wenn der verkaufspreis sich verzehnfacht
machen sie immer noch immense gewinne
und kohlekraftwerke haben wir nicht
investiert weil ökologisch sein wollten
dann entstehen bei den erzeugern von
strom gigantische zufalls gewinne die
auf der anderen seite industriebetriebe
in den ruin treiben und haushaltskassen
so belasten dass wir nachher sagen dass
soziale frieden ist gefallen deswegen
bin ich gegen diese gewinne gehabt mal
ganz kurz und da nur weiß sogar zur
interessantesten und darf sofort ran
vielleicht auch unsicher kiesewetter ich
weiß nicht ob alice motor da so genau im
bilde ist aber die frage wer verdient da
gerade so unfassbar gut das ist ja das
alte gesetz von der börse ja die dicken
das geld ist ja nie weg es hat ja nur
wer anderer mann verluste machen also
ist also wer wer sind die die sich
gerade richtig dumm und dämlich
verdienen ihre stadtwerke das ist ein
ganz kleiner spieler bitter
wer noch ich wäre dann wäre sie die
großen matches unterbrechen damit
wirklich die menschen draußen man
verstehen wie funktioniert dass der
strommarkt ist wirklich kompliziert aber
wir reden hier bei der preisgestaltung
nicht davon dass da irgendwelche bösen
leute sind die st
behauptet aber gerade sehr viel geld
merit order modell ja und es hat im
grunde genommen damit zu tun ich breche
mal runter damit man es wirklich
verstehen nehmen wir mal an wir werden
alle lieferanten wir können nicht strom
nehmen wir genau sagen wir produzieren
keine ahnung äpfel ok also
es gibt äpfel aus tübingen ja
gute äpfel gibt es rote rosen
diese äpfel die schafft der für ein euro
stück man einfach eine zahl das ist ja
auch so das ist ja auch so und jeder
kann in dieser runde mit fünf personen
10 äpfel liefern also wir brauchen am
ende müssen wir 50 apple zusammen
kriegen jetzt ist die frage auf dem
markt wie machen wir das denn es gibt
apple von markus lanz aus südtirol die
sind hand wie soll ich sagen sie zerlegt
und im gegensatz zu den
produktionskosten von einem euro kosten
10 euro wir haben einen markt und genau
das muss man verstehen das heißt am ende
sagt man ich brauche 50 äpfel und jetzt
geht es darum wie ist der preis wie
kommt der zustande und da ist sozusagen
der teuerste der bestimmt ganz
automatisch den rest so funktioniert im
ganz einfachen unser strommarkt heute
das bedeutet diejenigen die im grunde
genommen für sonne ja muss man überhaupt
nichts zahlen für wind auch nicht aber
die braunkohle die steinkohle oder dass
sich auch sollte er dieser tage bei den
kollegen der tatze interessanten
vergleich auch mit äpfeln lustigerweise
gelesen der das nochmal anschaulicher
machte sagte es gibt eine nachfrage nach
zehn äpfeln
austauschbare güter ja alles die gipfel
werden zum gleichen preis gern und es
entsteht die nachfrage nach einem elften
apfel
dann wird der preis so lange nach oben
gehen bis entweder einer aussteigt und
weil er sich diesen teuren apfel nicht
mehr leisten kann oder aber jemand ist
bereit diesen elfter apfel für sehr viel
geld woanders zu besorgen und damit geht
die preise auch für die anderen zehn
automatisch nach oben das ist sozusagen
die geschichte gibt es keine
echte die herren werk sind über das ist
einfach das ist kapitalismus beispiel
weil wir vielleicht ganz fundamental
eine frage stellen sollten nämlich ist
energie wirklich ein markt warum
in einem normalen markt habe nicht in
pully kaufe dann stelle ich irgendwann
fest da ist mir zu teuer und ich kaufe
nicht angeboten nachfrage aber bei
energie in einem industrieland sind wir
darauf angewiesen das heißt wir haben
nicht den korridor zu sagen auch wir
lehnen uns zurück und kommen durch
diesen winter ohne gas sondern die
gesamte debatte zeigt wie abhängig wir
sind was wir brauchen es und das ist für
mich die frage inwieweit diese
marktmechanismen die da man da drauf
gesetzt hat die auch vorzüge haben
wenige der günstig produziert der hatten
incentive also immer mehr zum beispiel
erneuerbare energien weil die viel
günstiger sind eben in der herstellung
und das ist eine frage die man heute
eigentlich stellen müssen was man in der
debatte merkt ist dass die alte idee des
freien marktes jetzt immer mehr durch
intervention kommt jetzt redet man von
über gewinnsteuern oder zu fassen sind
bis hin zu schlimm ich finde es ein sehr
stellung muss man irgendwann wissen
welche musik machen wir machen wir
entweder eine bei der wir uns
verabschieden von dem freien markt und
wir regeln das anders das ist ziemlich
kompliziert oder wir bleiben dabei und
dann nehmen wir vielleicht gas komplett
raus und sagen okay das spielt keine
rolle das ist politisch und müssen wir
anders handeln das ist wirklich
kompliziert und die sagen die augen denn
es gibt noch das internationale sich
sprachlich ist lang reiche anja und hier
spreche ich aber auch das thema
solidarität an frankreich braucht
zurzeit unseren überschüssigen strom im
winter werden sie ihre kernkraftwerke so
rasch nicht hochfahren können weil sie
niedrigwasser haben das wird auch im
winter einige zeit lang gehen und es ist
ein argument europäischer solidarität
wenn wir unsere kernkraftwerke die 3
über diese drei vier monate hinaus
laufen lassen bis wir uns europäisch
verstehen haben wann die kraft bei dem
wetter hätte ich jetzt hätte ich jetzt
ein schönes killerargument in belgien
hat gerade die laufzeit von zwei meilen
bis 2035 verlängert
europäische
in seine richtung sehr wohl um den die
richtung von boris palmer auch und wir
werden offensichtlich von ländern um uns
herum
gebeten unsere meiler doch bitte länger
laufen zu lassen und es hat noch mal
soll die faktisch noch mal gesehen isa
zwei niederbayern könnte mit diesem
verhalten brennstäben die der jetzt drin
sind mit einer leistung von 60 bis 70
prozent bismarcks einfach wie beim
erfahren würde gehen dann konnten ersatz
kern aus eigenem material physikalisch
keine ahnung wie das geht der kommt dann
zum einsatz und dann geht es bis juli
mit 80 prozent der leistung weiter es
soll mir doch keiner erzählen dass das
nichts bringt ja es ist nur strom den
wir gut gebrauchen können ist ein wort
gefallen das hat mit solidarität zu tun
wenn wir uns den strommarkt angucken
dann ist europa komplett vernetzt man
muss sich das mal vorstellen anfang des
jahres ist sogar die ukraine in den
europäischen stromverbund gekommen nun
ist erstmal vom gefühl her zu machen wir
kennen alle dieses brummen von 50 hertz
wird man manchmal hier im studio
exakt das gleiche brummen hört man zum
beispiel in kiew weil der strom über
europa exakt in gleicher phase da ist in
dem zusammenhang ganz kurz vor der ski
abstimmt es verboten dass wir auch strom
aus der ukraine kriegen im moment ganz
ehrlich das kann ich nicht beantworten
das im prinzip ja also man kann sich das
genau angucken im prinzip ist das ein
großer verbund wie bekommen natürlich
eher strom ist und aus frankreich aus
dem umfeld aber im prinzip könnte das
ist ja die idee man baute ein großes
stromnetz damit die schwankungen
kompensiert werden damit wie in diesem
sommer frankreich eben nicht mit einem
blackout steht bald in den großen
stromnetz dann von anderer seite
kiesewetter dass kriege auch angeboten
soweit ich weiß ja nur sind jetzt die 66
der elf meiler abgeschaltet worden also
was aus den anderen kernkraftwerken
läuft soweit ich weiß ja die sind im
stromnetz und wir bekommen strom
im ausgleichen aber das ist nicht eine
frage von die ukraine bietet meines
ihren liefern auch deutsche gleichen
stand ist das ist bestandteil eines
großen europäischen stromnetz ist also
sagen gib uns strom oder das ist genau
das was hochdynamisch im takt von kittel
stunden verhandelt wird der roboter dann
boris palmer das problem ist dass diese
frage die man eigentlich so wie sie das
tun nicht dann betrachten müsste
parteipolitisch aufgeladen ist und wir
reden hier über ein paar monate wir
reden über ideologie so ist dass das ist
schade wie sich die grünen haben die
sorge wenn sie in dieser frage nachgeben
dass die fdp reingeht und die frage nach
der zukunft der nuklearen energie neu
stellen die diskussion als grund sehen
ich weiß viele jahre länger laufen das
ist eben nicht um ein paar monate geht
sondern um eine zukunftsperspektive und
ich glaube sind uns um alle eigentlich
das atomare energie aus
unterschiedlichen gründen als
zukunftsenergie ausgedient hat und
deshalb kann man nicht sagt ich darüber
reden wie sie das getan haben sondern es
kommen eben parteipolitische erwägungen
dazu und das thema wird in ideologie
ertränkt so steht mir zu und jetzt würde
ich gern obwohl die stimmen zu dass bei
den grün natürlich nicht ideologie im
spielsystem und es sieht ja jeder partei
so parteien gibt es nicht ohne ideen das
heißt das was robert habeck gestern
verkündet hatte sei oder mit jürgen
getrieben kompromiss ob sie ist
ideologie nennen oder haltungen oder
grundsätzlich mir egal aber natürlich
steckt da was dahinter ist doch logisch
deswegen machen wir politik deswegen
stimmig der analyse ist interessiert
regen stimmig der analyse ausdrücklich
zu und ich habe wussten den anzug der
farbe ruhendes grün gewählt was für
einen grünen dieser hohen des bundes
grünen ich bin ja ruhen das mitglied man
deswegen habe ich ruhe sehen kann ich
das gefühl dass ich kann mich jetzt ganz
ruhig erklärt uns alles völlig verrückt
wie mein herr kiesewetter kollege
schwarz ganz so ganz das ist diese neue
verrückte cdu mit dem t shirt
oön kann es ganz ruhig erklären für
meine partei ist das robot habe ich
jetzt gemacht hat dieses gesetzlich
fixierte enddatum dieser meiler
aufzugeben ein riesenschritt sondern
auch mal würdigen wenn einer über seine
eigenen grenzen hinaus geht das hat er
gemacht und ich hätte tatsächlich gesagt
energiewirtschaftliche strikt betrieb
also das langsame auslaufen lassen der
energie aus diesen vorhandenen
brennstäben klüger aber das war zu viel
für meine partei ganz einfach und weil
dieser strikt betrieb aber wir als neues
mitglied können das einfach mal so groß
weil ich glaube ich kann es zu erklären
wer und ich verstehe auch das ist zu
wenig wenn du vor 40 jahren angefangen
hat auf demonstration so gegen
atomkraftwerke wir haben weil sie
verhindert in wien und in bruckdorf wo
überall die menschen jetzt holst du ja
sagen verlängerung dieser atomkraftwerke
das ist schlimm wenn man dann sagt ok
als kluger wirtschaftsminister habe ich
jetzt eine idee die mir die optionen
offen hält das gesetzliche entert umfeld
bzw es wird verschoben um vier monate
und ich habe vier monate zeit in den ich
reagieren kann wenn wir im dezember
merken es wird eng und man braucht diese
atomkraftwerke wirklich hat er die
möglichkeit den strick betrieb immer
noch zu beginnen und dann ist es an die
situation meine partei vielleicht
zähneknirschend ja sagen kann weil wir
uns gar nicht anders geht muss man halt
so aber im moment ist es nicht so weit
und deswegen ist ein kluger politischer
schachzug denn da gemacht hat ich würde
aber auch noch gerne dafür so der papst
regulierung des strommarktes wollte sie
nun genau ich würde gerne mal verlieren
sind wir wissen von hängen geblieben bei
der frage wer da gerade richtig geld
verdient genau und die frage ich meine
dieser strommarkt dieser energiemarkt
wenn man sich damit beschäftigt das ist
ja in wahrheit kein freier markt das ist
ja ein total regulierter markt bewegen
die frage könnte da nicht weiter gehen
und sagen freunde das ist jetzt der
preis und ende ich finde schon wir
müssen das mengenproblem und das preis
problem getrennt diskutieren das sind
zwei verschiedene fragen das
mengenproblem da gibt es für mich aber
eine ganz klare antwort es darf nicht
passieren dass die lichter ausgehen ist
darf nicht passieren dass der industrie
das gas abgedreht wird und was notwendig
ist um das zu fördern muss getan werden
wort evo ix wir brauchen dann mario kg
das preis problem ist davon getrennt zu
werden ist auch sehr sehr schwierig aber
menge und preis sind nicht unmittelbar
gekoppelt ist liegt an der marriott ist
nicht führt nicht dazu dass ich mehr
atomstrom habe plötzlich wird es
billiger ist einfach nicht der fall so
und wenn ich jetzt diesen mengenproblem
anschaue dann sag ich verstehe eines
nicht als aufsichtsratsvorsitzender
stadtwerke tübingen weiß ich dass ich
morgen den hebel um leben könnte und
alle strom kraftwerke die auf gas
basieren in tübingen ausschalten und es
würde nichts passieren denn wir haben
dann eben immer einen ölkessel und öl
ist lieferbar ist auch kein preis
problem und wir könnten sofort die ganze
fernwärme und übrigen umstellen auf öl
und das wäre ja offensichtlich richtig
in der auseinandersetzung mit putin und
offensichtlich richtig um gas zu sparen
für die deutsche industrie wir machen es
aber nicht warum machen wir das nicht
ich kann es nicht machen weil ich dafür
ins gefängnis gehen würde woran liegt es
das würde für die stadtwerke team ich
hab mir heute aktuellen zahlen noch mal
geben lassen mit den heutigen
börsenpreisen einen verlust bis märz
nächsten jahres von 25 millionen euro
bedeuten ich kann als
aufsichtsratsvorsitzender keinen 25
millionen schaden bei meinem eigenen
unternehmen verantworten dafür gehe ich
im knast das ist nämlich untreue das
heißt ich brauche einen neuen rahmen ich
brauche einen rahmen der stadtwerke
tübingen und da geht es ums leben zehn
prozent der
gasstrom der stromerzeugung in
deutschland zehn prozent etwas in
kraft-wärme-kopplungsanlagen viele davon
betreiben stadtwerke könnten wir morgen
umstellen weil es immer etwas mit öl
kraftwerken gibt zehn prozent ist
deutschland was die dimensionen in
deutschland wegen sind 20 prozent der
grösste gasverbrauch in tübingen ist
verstromung durch die stadtwerke gibt es
zwar durch öl und wir brauchen das
könnten die anderen auch kürzen prozent
in ganz deutschland könnten das ist eine
stelle ist volumens 18 oder zehn aber
das ist uns genug also da hätten wir das
öl gibt es also wirklich das problem des
öl ist auch kein problem das einzige
problem ist der wirtschaftlichen
nachteil den den strom den ich da
erzeuge die wärme kann ich zum gleichen
preis mit öl herstellen ist sogar
billiger aber der strom den ich erzeuge
den habe ich schon verkauft die
stadtwerke haben kunden die sind das
ganze jahr müssen beliefert werden dass
verträge und da steht auch ein preis
drin und wenn ich jetzt meine eigene
stromerzeugung ausschalte schon klar und
plötzlich kurzfristig strom kaufen an
der börse der käfig den streuer strobl
es überhaupt gibt es zehn mal teurer als
eine produktion und kosten und dann habe
ich 25 millionen und jetzt wäre einfach
meine bitte an die bundesregierung wir
brauchen ein angebot an die betreiber
dieser kraftwerke die diesen schaden
kompliziert bekommt unserem ausgemacht
wie viel das wäre ich lese reden in
deutschland von fünf milliarden gibt
sind die preise noch mal angezogen
vielleicht geht es auch in zehn
milliarden ist viel geld aber im
vergleich zu den 65 milliarden die das
aktuelle paket umfasst wäre es eine
investition in unsere zukunft ok und die
erhaltung unseres industriestandort
werden vor ich angst habe stehst du
jetzt ist gas weiter verschoben weil wir
da sparen das geld nicht finden um es zu
ersetzen durch öl und wenn dann die
abschaltung kommt dann wird deutschland
dem das realisiert dann haben wir eine
industrielle kernschmelze deren folgen
ich mir gar nicht ausmalen mich so ok
also sieben jahre für dessen kraft
verlängerung für einen bestimmten
zeitraum ich habe den strick betrieb
ganz kurz bei dem thema bleiben
industrielle kernschmelze also sie
plädieren dafür sozusagen aus gas zu
sparen stadtwerke wichtig mit öl lieber
diesen strom zu machen und die wärme die
es dafür braucht und wir könnten eine
menge gas sparen warum weil die deutsche
industrie gerade kiesewetter sie haben
gefallen kurz angedeutet auf dem am
stock geht oder wie muss man sich das
vorstellen
also ich höre wenn man da mal so rein
hört das schlimme dinge also ich würde
mal ganz einfach beim handwerken beginn
bäckereien die haben im schnitt 56
mitarbeiter wir haben im monat 900 euro
gas und inzwischen sind es für ihre öfen
fast 3000 euro das heißt also eine
verdreifachung bis vervierfachung der
gaskosten im betrieb pro monat ich hatte
am wochenende treffen mit der
bäckerinnung sagte der laib brot müsste
zwischen acht und zehn euro kosten ab
oktober und vergleichbar
papierherstellung toilettenpapier was
wird gelesen feuchttücher alle mit
jahren erstellt also wir haben hier eine
extreme preisspirale die kommen wird und
deswegen ist eben auch ein argument wie
kriege ich günstig den strom her lohnt
es sich aus der merit order das gas zu
nehmen der strom würde den bäcker an der
windenergie will die nicht helfen aber
die meine strom und von jahr zu stoppen
das würde helfen dass wir das irgendwann
seine sünden also sicher
damit war wohl der richtige weiter
zitieren
steile these kriegt man ärger und post
kriegt man auch wenn man sowas sagt aber
ich finde es gut dass sie sagen
zuallererst muss die wirtschaft
funktionieren und nicht die
privathaushalte da kann man ich will das
mal zu speziellen durchaus auch mal ein
bisschen mehr anziehen so ist das also
wir haben ja eine europäische regelung
ist es kann immer auch europäisch gucken
und in der europäische regelung heißt es
es gibt priorisierungen und das sind die
privathaushalte das sind
pflegeeinrichtungen krankenhäuser
soziale einrichtungen die bundeswehr und
die auch sicherheit polizeien
feuerwehren berufsfeuerwehren und erst
an zweiter stelle steht die wirtschaft
und ich glaube es würde wenig helfen
wenn die menschen mit arbeitslosengeld 1
oder entsprechend fortgesetzt
arbeitslosengeld 2 teils das bürgergeld
zu hause sitzen ihre temperaturen
einstellen aber eben nicht mehr arbeiten
deswegen ist das entscheidende dass die
wirtschaft funktioniert und das müssen
wir übergreifend hinbekommen das haben
wir im bundestag auch in den debatten
glaube ich gibt es wenig unterschiede
unter den parteien aber das
entscheidende ist aus meiner sicht dass
das zu wenig betrachtet wird sondern
eher geregelt wird ob die deutschen mit
24 grad oder mit 18 grad zurechtkommen
und mein appell ist hier politische
führung das eben auch vom bundeskanzler
von den parteivorsitzenden vielleicht
sogar übergreifend auch unter
einbeziehung der opposition gesagt wird
liebe bevölkerung haben zwei drei harte
jahre vor uns so lange wird der krieg
dauern wenn die ukraine nicht einem
diktat frieden zustimmen muss und um
diese zeit zu gewinnen und zu überprüfen
wer das hier ist ihre kamera sie handy 3
dieser könnte jetzt einmal hier zum
verzichte aufrufen hat das entscheidende
ist dass wir vernunft brauchen unsere
bevölkerung unter erheblichen
belastungen steht und diese belastungen
müssen wir abgeordnete verstehen und die
regierung erst recht und das bedeutet
dass wir alles tun müssen dass die
bevölkerung ein seht ihr schlägen vor
zwei drei schweren jahren und nicht das
nächste halbe jahr und deshalb ist es
wichtig dass rücklagen gebildet werden
können dass entlastungen erfolgen und
einiges an den paketen die zwischen
referenten auch für studierende sind ja
vernünftig auch bestimmte deckelungen
aber es reicht nicht wenn
wir einmal ganz kurz bestandsaufnahme
und danach eben vielleicht darüber warum
diese politische führung offenbar
vermisst wird bei ihnen hat man bewies
bei ihnen also unternehmen was was hören
sie als als mann von der basis vega ist
genau richtig in tübingen hagelloch hat
gerade in becker in der dritten
generation des saab 92 jahren dort weckt
bekanntgegeben dass er zum jahresende
aufhört begründung es rechnet sich nicht
mehr ich kann kein brötchen mehr und
keine brezel mehr produzieren zu den
preisen die ich noch bekomme ich habe
einmal die preise erhöht ergebnis ich
verkauf weniger die einnahmen bleiben
die gleichen ich habe es hin und her
gewendet ich kann die mehrkosten bei
mehl und bei energie nicht an die
verbraucher weitergeben ich schließe das
ist nur der anfang fürchte ich und 73
jahre alt bisschen größer 500
mitarbeiter die firma risch aus zügigen
eine der ganz wenigen überlebenden text
die industrie uns religion war mal ganz
groß in der textilwirtschaft ist fast
alles weg oder weisheit überleben warum
weil sie spitzen spezial textilien
herstellen zum beispiel den himmel im
autodach macht roche aus tübingen das
ist ein prozess der ist extreme
technologisch auf finde ich aber ich
auch vor allem von gas abhängig da
brauchst du 500 grad die machen so viel
abwärme in ihrer fabrik dass wir damit
letztes jahr eine auskopplung machen
können wir nehmen die abwärme dieses
industriebetriebs und können damit ein
stadtteil mit 2000 einwohnern komplett
heizen so viel so viel gas verbraucht
wahnsinn so und dieses unternehmen ist
schon preislich nicht mehr in der lage
zu überleben wenn jetzt noch eine
gasanlage kommt und die verträge
auslaufen und für das vierfache das gas
verlangt wird sagt mir da firmeninhaber
auftritte generation das werden wir
nicht überleben wenn wir nicht hilfen
bekommen und ist kritisch sehe ich ganz
laut ich finde die umverteilung die
derzeit gemacht wird richtig weil die
ärmsten der armen die kein brot und
keine heizung kaufen und kein strom
kaufen können der bricht diese
gesellschaft zusammen das liegt auf der
hand aber sie bricht genau so zusammen
wenn die quellen des wohlstands
versiegen wenn die industrielle basis
kaputt geht und das passiert wenn wir
nicht solchen unternehmen unter die arme
greifen lehrstelle in der politik die
müssten medien bei der gasanlage
ausgenommen werden energieintensive
betriebe können keine gas umlage
obendrauf bezahlen da muss eine ausnahme
gemacht werden und noch weiter nach
vorne geschaut wenn das gas abgedreht
wird dann sagt er mir meine
lieferkontrakte sind so wenig zwei
wochen nicht geliefert hat kriege ich
nie wieder ein vertrag dann ist es in
ostasien und das war's kann ich aus
deutschland dann nicht mehr liefern in
dieser industrie in unserem lande sind
500 arbeitsplätze in meiner stadt sind
riesiges desaster für jede familie von
betroffenen und das muss verhindert
werden und dann verstehe ich nicht warum
ich weiterhin gas verstromen muss noch
mal 20 prozent des gases in meiner stadt
geht in strom rein dieser betrieb
braucht es gas hatte ich darf es nicht
mal an sparten ich würde ja sogar sagen
liebe bundesregierung gar kein geld aber
dann lass mir das gas dann gebe ich mal
im industriebetrieb weil ich weiß dass
die steuern die der die nächsten zehn
jahre zeit vielfaches dessen sind weiß
ich jetzt zahlen muss um diesen ganzen
zurückzustellen darf ich ja auch nicht
weil die abschaltung macht ja die
bundesebene und was da auf uns zukommt
wird in seiner bedeutung finde ich
überhaupt nicht angemessen diskutiert
das ist letztlich gar nicht ernsthaft
was wir hier machen wir stehen wirklich
am abgrund einer deindustrialisierung
und dann lese ich dass da das da der
bundesgesetzgeber regelt dass ich das
rathaus in tübingen nicht mehr
beleuchten darf das schreibt der forcam
ich übrigens selber drauf dass man das
abschaltet aber solches symbol maßnahmen
dann vorgeschrieben und die wirklich
großen wichtigen schalthebeln die diebe
nutzen wir einfach nicht wann muss ich
einfach sagen das verstehe ich wenn ich
mit dem firmeninhaber noch breche das
verstehen der versteht es auch ihn und
jetzt habe ich eines gemacht habe sagt
dann müssen wir das ausprobieren zeigen
auch als ökologe trotzdem der hat vor
drei jahren eine riesige anlage in
betrieb genommen um den allerhöchsten
umweltstandard durchzusetzen alle abgase
die schon gereinigt sind laufen noch mal
durch eine verbrennungsanlage die gas
betrieben ist weil erst bei 1000 grad
das letzte schadstoff molekül kaputt ist
das weiß ranga yogeshwar besser als ich
ich würde vorschlagen dass für diesen
winter auszuschalten das hat keinerlei
gesundheitseffekte sind die letzten zwei
prozent perfektion die wir uns in
deutschland leisten ich würde auch als
mensch in meiner stadt in tübingen sagen
ok auf diese zwei prozent schadstoff
elimination die es bis vor drei jahren
nicht gab wir haben alle gut gelebt in
tübingen die verzichte ich dann mit
diesem winter das gas nicht verboten
diese großen maßnahmen damit wir durch
den mieter konnten die vermisse ich für
unsere industrie